shut in is the story of Naomi Watts a
stepmother caring for her stepson who
has been paralyzed in a terrible car
accident and a huge winter storm blows
in and traps them inside this house
there's also a young boy missing in this
storm which is weighing on her mind as
well and she's encountering strange
things in the middle of the night and
she's not exactly sure what's going on
and neither are we as audience members
because this movie is terrible there
were no screenings for this movie that I
know of anyway so I went to the theater
and paid for a ticket today and I was
actually kind of excited I liked Naomi
Watts quite a bit in regards to scary
films that she's been involved with the
ring I think is really good and I like a
good winter storm movie where the
characters are trapped and you feel
claustrophobic I love those aspects with
this movie and aesthetically it delivers
some of that you feel like you're in
this house and the house is encasing it
on you because there are some good
moments of sound design but for the most
part I'm blown away by how awful this
screenplay is in fact it's so bad it's
one of the worst of the year if every
horror movie cliche and trope could
manifest themselves as a person grow
hands and fingers and then start to type
they wrote this let's see where do I
even start
a racoon jumps out and scares the
out of Naomi Watts and there's a loud
jump scare virtually every scare that
occurs in this movie is a false scare
something it's supposed to be scary that
ends up being just a dream or a man
that's kind of interested in Naomi Watts
and maybe as flirtatious with her a
little bit shows up and goes down here
that's what we're dealing with people
for the large majority of this movie's
runtime it was just bad the first two
acts were just filled with so many dream
sequences and so many false scares and
it was getting annoying yes but I was at
least watching it without rolling my
eyes every two minutes the third act of
this movie is an absolute disaster
everything that occurs in the last 20
minutes of this movie makes everything
else that happened before it make zero
sense Oliver Platt is in this film and
he basically exists to be that character
that Naomi Watts skypes from time to
time to ask him for advice
because we all love skype scenes a Skype
scene can work in a movie I've seen it
work the visit shamless last movie had a
few good Skype scenes because the
dialogue was okay
in this movie it's basically Naomi Watts
going you know I'm not sleeping too well
oliver platt psycho well you know it's
you've been through a lot of trauma yeah
I think it's a little more than that
actually well what do you mean I think
there might be some ghosts in my house
oh come on ghosts don't exist you know
that yeah well I'm pretty sure there
might be something going on hahaha
you're just being silly it's that times
10 over and over again the same scenes
with her and Oliver Platt going back and
forth on skype it's horrible it's also
one of those scary movies where every
character makes the dumbest decision
they could in the moment you're
constantly looking at people who are
splitting up and you're like why are you
leaving that person there you know why
would you do that what are you doing my
god the direction of the movie is
acceptable there's nothing really much
to it there's one great shot near the
end where a silhouette is cast over a
staircase it's an aerial shot I was like
wow that's a great shot it's a kind of
shot that would end up on the one
perfect shot Twitter this director comes
primarily from TV he directed a few
episodes of daredevil he's perfectly
fine at what he's doing but the
direction of this movie comes off as
just acceptable but what can you really
do with a screenplay this contrived and
this awful speaking of what can you do
with a terrible screenplay poor Naomi
Watts is stranded in the storm of this
movie she is trying this is a movie
about a paralyzed boy who was in a car
accident he's stuck in a chair a storm
has encased these characters in this
movie they can't leave he can't move
that's how I felt during this entire
film in this theater I'm gonna give shut
in an F I'll tell you what I've got to
talk about this ending and how it
doesn't make sense so if you don't care
about that I'm gonna get into it
spoiler warning because I'm sorry I pay
to see this movie it's out in theaters
who cares don't see this movie it's not
worth your time or your money so
basically the paralyzed boy isn't
actually paralyzed he's just pretending
to be paralyzed that's right
he wanted his stepmoms affection so bad
and when this young boy played by Jacob
Tremblay from room really good movie by
the
wait goes missing and Naomi watch starts
to worry about him he gets jealous
so when Jacob Tremblay shows up at Naomi
Watts his house she tries to take care
of him for one night the paralyzed kid
who's not paralyzed gets up and takes
this kid and traps him in this house
Naomi Watts is hearing where it sounds
at night she's waking up in the middle
of strange dreamlike scenarios and
apparently her stepson has just been
drugging her medically every day the
script is filled with so many
inconsistencies and for the first two
acts I was just like it's bad it's not
very good that third act and that reveal
made this movie one of the worst horror
films of the year
so yeah I don't see it you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching if you missed my review of a
rival I announced I'm going to be going
to AFI Fest
in LA I randomly decided to jump on a
plane this Sunday and go check it out
I'm going to try to see a lot of movies
and get early reviews for you guys I'm
going to do my best to do that thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]